it's not bad news okay
um i do have something to tell you
though we've been doing this for three
years
and i mean i'm sure you've noticed i'm
usually not in front of the camera
and i mean i did that for a reason i
don't i prefer
to stay behind the camera basically what
i'm trying to say
is that i'm doing something that is
completely outside my comfort zone
i'm starting a podcast and in the
podcast i'm always going to be in them
because i'm the host i've been wanting
to start a podcast for like two years
and just my fear of being in front of
the camera has stopped me i get a lot of
comments saying sorry
you should start a podcast i love just
listening to your videos on my drive to
work
or like when i'm doing laundry i just
put my headphones in and i listen and
i'm just like dang i wish
i wasn't so nervous in front of the
camera so i could actually
make a podcast but i'm that's what i'm
doing now
i'm getting over my fears let me tell
you why it's been so hard for me to
start a podcast
even though i've been wanting to do it
for two years well first of all i'm the
type of person where
if i want to do something i just like do
it right away this thing of like wanting
to do this and not being able to
it's been like eating away at me for a
really long time so i just got to the
point where
i don't know i was just like i preach
this whole being bold thing why can't i
just be
a little bold and do this but yeah let
me get back to why
it's so hard to do a podcast i'm a
pretty
shy person until you get to know me of
course but like
when people tell me like wow you must be
so outgoing you meet so many people i
just think to myself
little do you know but the thing is like
when you have like a passion for
something you're willing to like grind
through
things that hold you back i rely heavily
on skills that like i've just practiced
over and over again i've just always
felt like to be
a podcast host you just have to be like
naturally gifted
and able to ignore the camera
and the fact that you're being recorded
and
if the person for for example my worst
fear is like to have a guest on
who says the most amazing story and i
just reply in a really dumb way and i'm
just like
do i put this episode up and look dumb
or do i not put it up and just lose this
amazing story
so i don't know it's just it's been a
lot of
overthinking and a lot of fear that's
been holding me back but obviously
we're here because i finally did it
that's the good news
i do want to warn you guys though uh
this is something where
i'm learning as i go like i could have
just like
practiced on my own for a really long
time gone really good at it and then
launched it but
i just thought it would be cool to get
your feedback as i look super awkward in
front of the camera
and like i don't know i guess it'll be
fun to look back on my first episode
once we're like 100 episodes in i've
been trying to figure out a way to
announce it
and i thought why not just do
what i'm best at being in front of the
camera that's sarcasm
and i don't know what it is about you
guys honestly like you just have some
sort of magic
i know a lot of people say this that
they have the best subscribers but
i'm like i think i'm being completely
unbiased when i say that no
i have the best subscribers i'm still a
hot mess but i was even more of a hot
mess
before you guys so i mean thank you for
that
but i'm saying all this to say that i
know how powerful
your kindness can be because i've lived
it firsthand
for the past three years and i guess
what
i'm trying to ask is whatever magic it
is
that you guys do and have done for my
youtube channel
i hope you'll consider also working that
magic
for my podcast because like i i do want
to give it a solid shot
i don't want to do it see that it's not
going so well and kind of give up on the
idea
and i know that the only way i could
give it a solid shot is if
we all go into it together i don't want
to half-ass it
i want to see if we can actually do it
so
if you don't mind i'm going to list a
few things that you could do
to best help launch my podcast it's
going to launch january 12th
and i guess the first step is listen
hopefully you'll love it
but if you hate it please let me know in
private that you hate it because
i might be a little fragile the first
the first few episodes but if you love
it
and you think to yourself you know what
i'm going to work my magic
then these are the things that will help
most
first leave a five star review on apple
podcast
i don't know why this is so important
but everyone keeps telling me like
tell people to leave you a five star
review the podcast is going to be
available everywhere basically like
spotify anchor
google podcasts and a lot of others and
of course following and subscribing on
them will help but
the most important thing it's really
important to get a lot of five star
reviews on apple podcast and so i
thought we would have some fun with it
if you decide to leave a five star
review i thought it'd be cool for you to
answer
this question who's one stranger you
still remember
so under a five star review on apple
podcast
answer the question who's one stranger
you still remember
i'll read through every single one i
promise even if there are 10 000 i'm
going to read through every single one
i'm going to choose some to share on my
instagram story so leave your instagram
handle as well if you want me to tag you
and of course obviously subscribing and
following on whatever platform you
listen on or all of them
if you want to go all out and even
though the podcast launches on the 12th
i actually have my trailer and my
profile
up now so you can start doing all these
things today i'll make sure to have my
podcast links in the description
another thing i think would really help
is to share the podcast
with someone you think would love it so
if you listen to the podcast and it
makes you think of someone
you think would love it send it to them
for every episode
every single one just send it to people
we're gonna learn as we go
we're gonna grow as we go and how how
sick would it be
if we made like the top charts can you
imagine oh my god
i don't really have any like
goals i don't know like i mean it would
be cool to make like the top charts but
i feel like that's just like so out
there i don't even know
if that's possible but um i guess that
could be a goal
okay you know what when i had 300
subscribers i made it a goal to hit a
million and i thought it was impossible
at the time
so let's do the same again right now
obviously it's not about the numbers
but um like as a creator it is cool to
get more people
just to see what you make to hear what
you make so i try to limit
the amount of times like i put number
goals out there but
it is fun to do every once in a while
just so you could look back and be like
oh my gosh
like i can't believe that happened and
also i'll be posting the video version
on
i even tell you guys what the podcast is
about oh my god
okay are you do you want to know let me
tell you what the podcast is about
it's actually super exciting okay i want
the podcast to be
a podcast version of my channel and how
i thought was best to do this
is for me to set up two chairs two
microphones
and two cameras of course in public on
sidewalks
at parks i sit on one chair and the
other chair is for my guest
who has to be a stranger that i meet on
the spot that day
i get them in the chair and i have them
answer the questions you've seen on my
channel i get them to tell me their
secrets
i get them to do something bold like
maybe call their crush
and i guess the only difference between
my podcast and my channel
is that you get to know these strangers
on a deeper level
i didn't think that was possible but
turns out it is
for example on my channel you see like
30 strangers per episode
and at most maybe one of their segments
is two minutes long
so now just imagine that one stranger
who has a two minute segment on my
episode
now has an entire hour i know you'll
fall in love with these people because
i've been falling in love with them and
their story
it's just been like a shift in the way i
do things
um before like i would just meet someone
for a couple minutes maybe we'd talk for
like five to ten minutes off camera if
they were willing but
this is just like i've become friends
with almost
every single person who i've done who
i've interviewed so far so it's been
pretty cool
and another cool thing is i'll have like
follow-up episodes i'm sure
you guys will like based on the stories
i've heard so far you guys are to want
to know follow-ups
other things i'm considering doing for
the podcast is this thing called thoriz
voicemail
if you guys follow me on instagram
you'll see that like i have this number
you could call in
and leave a secret for my voicemail and
this might be like bonus
audio at the end of each episode but
i'll play basically a bunch of
voicemails from you guys
sharing your secrets there's just so
many there's so much i want to do
and i think the more i overcome my fears
the more
freedom i'll have to be able to do this
and that's really exciting and
nerve-wracking it's
like a mixture of such opposite feelings
like i'm super excited but super nervous
like super stressed but like super
anxious in a good way i don't know it's
just it's been an interesting couple of
months leading up to this
but yeah that's what it's about i mean
this video is really all over the place
if you're still here thank you i think
that's it i think that's all
i wanted to say did i even talk i didn't
even tell you guys what it's called
oh my god this is the worst announcement
video ever
the podcast is called oh my gosh this
the podcast is called
how perfect i have it right here okay so
here is the big reveal i didn't even
plan on having this be a big reveal was
just because i forgot to tell you
but now it's a big reveal i'm gonna
reveal the name but let me go over all
these things one more time
january 12th the podcast is going to
launch each episode will air
every tuesday the video version will air
a few days later on my youtube channel
listen to the podcast first try to
imagine what you think the guests look
like
and then come on my youtube channel
maybe before you watch the video
leave a comment guessing what you think
that they would look like
share the podcast with your friends and
then
obviously the most important thing leave
a five star review on apple podcast i'll
make sure to link everything in the
description
okay so now for the big reveal
i'll reveal the name and we'll end this
with the preview
of the podcast the podcast is going to
be called
hey stranger is that in focus
there it is that's pretty much it thank
you guys for everything
i love you so much and we'll meet on
january 12th
the day my podcast launches
hey stranger
hello to everyone listening my name is
thoria this is the hey stranger podcast
and before we start let me set the scene
for you i'm currently sitting in a chair
on my local park which also happens to
be one of the biggest tourist
attractions
in my city across from me is an empty
chair and on today's
and every episode that empty chair will
be filled one by one by people of
different backgrounds
mindsets and walks of life the only
criteria
is that they are a stranger